- Sous cette piste d'athlétisme
flambant neuve, se cache
l'une des infrastructures
les plus imposantes
de Montréal.
Il faut descendre bien plus bas
pour le comprendre.
De chaque côté de ce couloir
d'à peine 1 mètre de large,
il y a une force colossale.
SYLVAIN OUELLET, responsable,
eau et infrastructures, Mtl.
- Ici, on est vraiment dans
l'entraille du réservoir
Rosemont. Derrière chacun de
ces murs là, y'a 110 000 mètres
cubes d'eau potable,
6 mètres de haut
de chaque côté.
- C'est toute la dynamique
de distribution...
- C'est le directeur du service
de l'eau qui joue le rôle
de capitaine de ce navire.
Du haut d'une passerelle,
il nous montre la salle
des machines : cinq pompes
qui vont injecter l'eau
dans le réseau.
ALAIN LARRIVÉE, dir. eau
potable, Service de l'eau, Mtl.
- C'est un réservoir qui a été
abandonné à la fin des années 70
et qu'on remet aujourd'hui
même en fonction à Montréal.
- Cela faisait 40 ans
qu'il ne servait plus.
Et pour le réactiver, il a fallu
repartir à zéro, ou presque.
Reconstruire une toute nouvelle
station de pompage,
revoir l'étanchéité
des réservoirs qui ressemblent
aux mines du royaume
des Nains de Tolkien.
- Ça, c'était avant
de les inonder d'eau potable.
- Cette eau qui dort maintenant,
en attendant de couler
au robinet.
- On ajoute 40 % de la capacité
donc c'est gigantesque,
220 000 mètres cubes.
Il y a 1000 litres par mètre
cube, donc faites le calcul.
- On l'a fait et ça représente
61  piscines olympiques.
Cette nouvelle réserve n'était
pas un luxe, malgré son coût
de près de 200 millions
de dollars, des dépenses
engagées sous l'ère Tremblay.
Il faut savoir que, personne
peut se priver très longtemps
d'eau potable.
Si demain matin là,
si l'eau potable arrête,
en quelques heures à peine,
les hôpitaux peuvent
plus fonctionner.
La mise en service
de ce réservoir-ci va nous
permettre également d'entamer
des travaux majeurs dans
d'autres infrastructures
de l'eau notamment la station de
pompage du réservoir McTavish.
- Relier le réservoir Rosemont
au réseau d'aqueduc a été
un défi parfois majeur.
Il a fallu creuser dans le roc
avec un tunnelier, en diagonale
à partir de la rue Notre-Dame,
pour faire passer une conduite
sous les résidences.
Pas d'affaissements à signaler.
Le service de l'eau a
une obsession : la discrétion.
- Aujourd'hui, on se plaît
à dire que notre objectif
est de passer inaperçu.
- Car pendant la phase de mise
en service, jusqu'en décembre,
des désagréments pourraient
survenir.
- C'est possible que certains
citoyens aient de l'eau colorée,
mais ça reste potable,
on surveille ça étroitement.
Il y a tout un plan
d'intervention qui est prêt.
Il y a une équipe de contrôle.
- Quand on dit "certains
citoyens", c'est tout de même
jusqu'à 770 000 personnes,
car ce réservoir alimentera
désormais une grande partie
de l'est et du sud
de l'île de Montréal.
La discrétion, c'est aussi,
et peut-être surtout
l'intégration au quartier.
Difficile de savoir qu'il y a
ici la plus grande réserve
d'eau potable traitée du Québec.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M